House of the Dragon has plenty of dark
scenes but this part of episode 7 may be
the darkest literally and that's the
least controversial thing about this
season that has fans up in arms spoilers
ahead House of the Dragon episode 1 The
Heirs of the Dragon revolves around a
tournament heralding the birth of the
new Prince viserys is sure it'll be a
boy or queen Emma just wants an end to
her miserable pregnancy her labor is
intercut with attorney the knights smash
each other's faces but the real horror
unfolds in Emma's bedroom the maesters
tell viserys that they cannot save Emma
but they may yet save the child It's
upsetting enough that viserys is given
control over Emma's body it's worse
still that he can't bring himself to
tell her the truth Emma suffers
excruciating pain and panic as The
maesters Not So carefully slice or open
and pull the infant from her womb she
dies moments later and baby Balon
perishes before the day is through some
viewers felt the episode should have had
a trigger warning and many lamented at
the Game of Thrones Universe was still
torturing and disposing of women from
shock value
we meet David's mistress masaria and The
Heirs of the Dragon then we get to know
her better in episode 2 the Rogue Prince
Damon steals a dragon egg and takes off
for Dragonstone on karaxis with the
supposedly pregnant massaria Otto and
the kingsguard arrive to negotiate his
surrender
welcome to Dragonstone Otto
but rhaenyra and Cyrax have everything
under control she lands a dragon
de-escalates the situation and recovers
the egg it turns out masaria isn't
really with child and she's not happy to
have been used in Damon's scheme I have
been sold this property more times than
I care to come
beginning in Homeland I can no longer
recall viewers were fine with the story
they just couldn't wrap their heads
around macario's accent as Fire and
Blood details massaria is a dancer from
lease who's smarter and more capable
than most people assume but the choice
of accent exoticizes her and is simply
difficult to understand no one else from
this region of George R.R Martin's World
sounds this way nor does actress sonoya
Mizuno who was raised in Somerset
England
as if pimping out his daughter weren't
bad enough Auto Hightower takes things
even further in episode 3 second of his
name as soon as Allison gives birth to
little aegon Otto begins scheming to put
his grandson on the Iron Throne this
episode follows a hunt held to celebrate
the boy's second birthday the hand uses
the opportunity to sway viserys with
tradition and symbols I've never been
one for signs of importance but if the
gods did wish to show their favor but
when he doesn't seem to be getting
anywhere he changes tactics princess
rhaenyra is still in need of a husband
you must marry
when viserys vents about the political
problems this presents Otto suggests
that perhaps the two-year-old Prince
aegon and the 17 year old princess
rhaenyra could marry each other the
Targaryen King with his long family
history of incest bulks at the idea
besides even though he's 15 years her
Junior we wouldn't want to inflict
aegon's depravity and abuse on poor rain
era episode 4 of House Of The Dragon
King of the narrow sea is among the most
salacious hours of television set in
Westeros so far rainy Rivera nearly
hooks up with her Uncle Damon before she
coerces her employee and sworn protector
sir Kristen Cole into bed then she
swears on her dead mother that what we
just saw happen didn't really happen
overall Rainier is wildness viewers
found another sex scene heart of the
stomach Allison to settling in for the
nights when a servant interrupts her
peace
Pardon Me Your Grace
the King has requested your presence
this is an order and not an offer as
rhaenyra is enjoying sowing her oats
Alison lies still an expressionless
underneath the king who is as fans
pointed out visibly ill not even the
queen of the Seven Kingdoms rules her
own body
Auto Hightower might be the force behind
the Green's treachery but sir Kristen
Cole who carries out most of Hightower
schemes might go down as the most hated
character on House of the Dragon after
their dalliance Christine asrenera to
run away with him she refuses but
doesn't exactly reject him merely
explaining she must fulfill her duties
as heir
I am the crown
oh I will be
it soon becomes clear that Kristen never
loved rainyra he's an insecure
possessive hypocrite with the shortest
ever fuse and the longest ever grudges
which makes fans absolutely loathing at
the fees to kick off raniera's Wedding
to Leonard valarian the groom's not
entirely secret boyfriend Joffrey susses
out that the princess and her sworn
protector must be sleeping together
Joffrey doesn't realize their
relationship is past tense so when he
approaches sir Kristen to form an
alliance he's tragically unprepared for
the night's Extreme overreaction as a
gathered wedding guest take to dancing
Kristen knocks Joffrey to the floor then
beats him until his face is pulverized
beyond recognition we don't know what
precisely Kristen's motivation is he
might be worried word of his broken vows
of Chastity will get out so perhaps he's
simply spiteful whatever the reason fans
find this vicious murder abominable
Joffrey and Lenor appear to have a
healthy loving partnership to many
including the advocate Joffrey's murder
feels like a particularly egregious
example of media's tendency to kill off
gay characters
healthy relationships are rare in
Westeros so when fans miss an
opportunity to see one unfold they get
upset Harwin strong doesn't get many
lines prior to episode 6 The Princess
and the queen non-book readers may have
entirely missed him admiring Rainier at
the hunt or bumping into her on the
street of silk
and who might you be running from now
it's a hobby
princess
but after the 10-year time Jump we can
tell from pretty obvious context clues
that Harwin and Rainier are very fond of
each other and have had a relationship
for most of the previous decade he's the
real father of her three boys and is as
Dodie and a family man as he can be
under the circumstances he tells his own
father in response to rumors you have
your honor and I have mine that honor
compels him to defend renyra and her
sons against Kristen and his insults by
way of a good strong punch unfortunately
this costs him his job and soon after
his life when they say their goodbyes he
and rhaenyra make eyes at each other but
a last breakbone says he's known must
leave the princess and princes without
so much as a goodbye kiss this irritated
fans who might have liked a positive
scene of physical contact after so many
portrayals of assault and abuse bailing
that bands of Harwin just wish he could
have stuck around a little longer
episode 7 of season 1 driftmark sent
fans into a tizzy but they weren't upset
by violence or cruelty they were
bothered by the lighting driftmark opens
with Lena's Twilight funeral after the
sun goes down Damon and Rainier
consummate their 15 years of flirtation
on the beach while Eamonn sneaks out to
test drive vegar
Vega is my mother's Dragon your mother's
dead
Vega has a new Rider now in the
aftermath Eamon instigates a brawl and
loses an eye also the dragon fans
complain that they couldn't see what was
going on due to the episode's extremely
dim lighting many compared the
installment to the infamous season 8
Game of Thrones episode the long night
the long-awaited Battle of Winterfell
underwhelmed audiences despite its
record-breaking scale because everything
was so darn dark when fans expressed
their outrage that this happened again
with driftmark the show defended the
lighting as a purposeful artistic Choice
since House of the Dragon takes place in
a world without electricity a certain
dimness is understandable but many fans
believe this nod to authenticity
interrupts basic storytelling while
Damon Kristen and even Otto age well
from episode to episode King viserys
looks more and more worse for the wearer
but everyone's surprised he's at his
most heroic when he's had his most
decrepit in episode 8 the lord of the
tides George R.R Martin told actor Patty
considine that he prefers his take on
the character to his own comparing
considine's viserys to King Lear fans
agree championing viserys's last stand
for his daughter water and lamenting his
final family dinner then comes the
misunderstanding to end all
misunderstandings with his final breath
the withered King thinks he's continuing
a life or death conversation with his
daughter when really he's talking to his
wife he means to tell rhaenyra that he
believes in aegon's dream and what's
more he believes the prince that was
promised will come from her line
it's the call
but Allison wrongfully interprets these
phrases to mean that he wants their son
aegon to succeed him instead of setting
things right viserys messes everything
up just when he was finally ruling the
realm and his family with strength and
solidity book readers were particularly
taken aback by this development and Fire
and Blood Otto and Allison usurped the
throne just because they want to the
show invented ending completely changes
the reason the dance of the Dragon
starts at all which many fans find
unnecessary and frustrating
the drama that's been building up all
season comes to a head in episode 9 the
green Council when the green sees power
it takes a lot of objectionable Behavior
to pull off this coup Kristen brutally
kills Lord beesberry during a small
council meeting Otto seeks to
assassinate the other half of viserys's
family the servants are imprisoned and
renice is kept captive in a room we find
out that aegon II not only has Myriad
bastards running around flea bottom he
spends his spare time at child fighting
pits oh and mellies kills hundreds of
commoners while escaping the dragon pit
but what really upsets viewers is the
price Laris puts on this information
Allison's personal master of Whispers
approaches her with some Intel
concerning her father before he spills
the beans he wants something in return
Allison takes off her shoes when that
doesn't produce the desired result she
removes her stockings this all happens
without a word being spoken between them
which is proof enough that it's happened
before she turns her head as Laris
enjoys the sight of her naked feet Laris
is exploiting Allison and Allison knows
it but there's nothing she can do this
squirmy his vintage Game of Thrones it's
out of left field gross and meant to
shock us indeed fans couldn't stop
talking about this moment after the
green Council aired even die hard
rainyro fans can't help but feel for the
queen in this moment twins Jaime and
Cersei Lannister's long-term
relationship is at the heart of their
dysfunction on Game of Thrones but both
the creators and fans of House of the
Dragon are more on board with Damon and
Rainier's romance though their uncle and
niece maybe the fact that it's a
Targaryen tradition makes him okay with
it maybe it's just that Matt Smith has
chemistry with everybody maybe it's at
once they exchange their very particular
marriage vows Damon and rhaenyra seem
pretty happy together whatever the
reason season 1 got many to root for
this uncommon couple so viewers were
understandably shaken by the moment
Damon grabs his wife by the throat in
episode 10 The Black Queen rhaenyra is
considering Allison's terms she feels
viserys taster Was preparing for the
coming war in the North and holding the
realm together whether she sits on the
Iron Throne while doing that is of less
consequence she complies this in Damon
thinking he's been let in on the secret
heard of aegon's dream
the secret
it's being passed from King to West in
seconds time but he hasn't Damon seems
to become enraged by the thought that
rhaenyra might be a cautious and Omen
Savvy ruler like her father was he grows
even angrier when he realizes viserys
didn't trust him with this information
[Music]
but I believe that you though we've seen
Damon react impulsively on several
occasions many viewers felt this abuse
was out of character notably the scene
doesn't occur in Fire and Blood Damon
isn't a hero and isn't even a good
husband to Rainier in the book but this
moment still feels like a bridge too far
to plenty of fans
foreign
[Music]